[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग तो एक बार सबसे
पहले मुझे यह बता दीजिए कि सबको मेरी आवाज
आ रही है या नहीं आ
रही
ब
क्या आवाज नहीं आ रही
क्या
ब
ओके थैंक यू तो लास्ट क्लास में जो डे थ
थी उसमें थोड़ा टेक्निकल इशू हो गया था तो
हमने बीच में छोड़ना पड़ा था तो एक बार यह
मुझे बता दीज जो लोग थे लास्ट क्लास में
क्या सभी को मेरी जो क्लास थी समझ में आई
थी या नहीं आई थी जो टॉपिक था हमारा
कोटिंग वो सबको समझ में आया था या नहीं था
यह बता दीजिए सरली अगर किसी ने देखा होगा
तो टॉपिक समझ में आया होगा अदर वाइज नहीं
आया होगा तो बता दीजिए एक
बार
ब
बताइए एक
बार एक काम करता हूं मैं कंटिन्यू करता
हूं पता नहीं चैट में कुछ चल रहा है आप
लोगों का जो लोग नए होंगे उनको कुछ पता
नहीं
होगा दोबारा से रिपीट करता हूं कि लास्ट
क्लास में मैंने क्या पढ़ाया था आपको देख
लास्ट क्लास में मैंने बताया था कोटिंग
क्या होता है बेसिकली कोटिंग क्या होता है
कि कोटिंग इ अबाउट रिमूविंग स्पेशल मीनिंग
ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स यह कोटिंग होता है तीन
टाइप्स की कोटिंग होती है बैक स्लस सिंगल
कोट डबल कोट जो आपको स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे
रही होगी बैक स्लस का मतलब क्या होता है
कि बैक स्लस जिस भी कैरेक्टर के सामने यूज
किया जाएगा उस कैरेक्टर का इमीडिएट उस
कक्टर क्या करेगा स्पेशल जो मीनिंग होगा
उसको रिमूव कर देगा और जो सिंगल कोड क्या
करेगा सिंगल कोड के अंदर जितने भी
कैरेक्टर्स होंगे अगर उनमें से किसी भी
कक्टर का स्पेशल मीनिंग होगा तो उसको
रिमूव कर देगा डबल कोट का मतलब क्या होता
है डबल कोट भी सेम काम करता है सिंगल कोड
की तरह बट डिफरेंस यह है कि इसके डबल कोट
के अंदर जितने भी कैरेक्टर्स होंगे उनका
भी स्पेशल मीनिंग सभी का रिमूव कर दिया
जाए एक्सेप्ट डॉलर साइन एंड बैकटिक्स बट
एक फ्लेक्सिबल दी हुई है डबल कोट के अंदर
आप क्या कर सकते हो कि कि अगर आप चाहो कि
डॉलर साइन है जो बैकटिक्स है उसका भी अगर
आप स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव करना चाहते तो आप
डबल कोड्स के अंदर बैक स्लस का यूज कर
सकते हो और अगर आप बैक का यूज करोगे तो वो
इनका मीनिंग जो स्पेशल मीनिंग था उसको भी
रिमूव कर देगा अगर एक किसी भी कैरेक्टर का
स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव हो गया तो हम उस
कैरेक्टर को बोलेंगे कोटेड या एस्केप
कक्टर कोट हो गया या एस्केप हो गया अदर
वाइज किसी भी कक्टर स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव
नहीं किया हमने वहा पर कोटिंग यूज नहीं
किया तो उसको हम बोलेंगे अनकोटेड अब मैं
प्रैक्टिकली बताता हूं क्योंकि लास्ट
क्लास में प्रैक्टिकली बता नहीं पाया था
थोड़ टेक्निकल इशू होने की वजह से तो एक
काम क्या करता हूं मैं आपको अभी
प्रैक्टिकली ले चलता हूं दूसरी स्कन के
ऊपर और हम प्रैक्टिकली इस चीज को सीखते
हैं
एक ब मैं आपके लिए स्क्रीन का साइज बढ़ा
कर देता हूं सो दैट कि आपको क्लियर विजिबल
हो जाए आपकी फोन स्क्रीन के ऊपर भी
ठीक
चलो अभी मैं आपको दिखाता हूं कि कोटिंग
कैसे काम करती है कोटिंग के तो प्रैक्टिकल
से आपको शो करके दिखाता हूं फर एपल मुझे
क्या करना है मैंने एकको करना है एकको और
मैंने लिखा है
सचिन एंड सचिन एंड नितेश एंड आई टीई एस एच
नितेश मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं यह प्रिंट
करना चाता हूं बट क्या है कि आप सबको पता
है कि जो एंड है जो मैंने यहां पर ये यूज
किया एम परट बोल सकते हैं जिसको हम जो
उसको यूज किया है इसका क्या मतलब यह भी
इसका मतलब होता है बैकग्राउंड मतलब क्या
कि यह भी एक स्पेशल कैरेक्टर है यह भी
क्या है एक स्पेशल कैरेक्टर है अगर किसी
ने लिनक्स नहीं पढ़ा तो मैं बता देता हूं
एक स्पेशल कैरेक्टर जिसका मतलब क्या है ये
आपके जिसका
मतलब कि
ये इसका स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव कर देता सॉरी
सॉरी सॉरी फॉर ट मैं एक कॉल आ गया था
जिसका मतलब क्या क्या है कि जो एंड है
जस्ट ए मिनट गाइस जस्ट ए मिनट होल्ड ऑन
थोड़ा
डिस्टरबेंस
ओके कंटिन्यू करते हैं थोड़ा डिस्टरबेंस
था तो एक काम मैं आपको बताता हूं जो ए पर
है जो एंड का मतलब होता है कि आपकी किसी
कमांड को क्या करता है बैकग्राउंड में रन
कर देता है अगर आपको नहीं मालूम है तो मैं
आपको बता देता हूं ओके तो अब मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं कि मैं एक को प्रिंट करना
चाहता सचिन एंड नितेश बट क्या जैसे ही
मैंने हिट एंटर हिट किया तो इसने क्या कर
दिया कि जो एक को सचिन को बैकग्राउंड में
रन कर दिया और नितेश कोई कमांड नहीं तो
उसको क्या बोल दिया कमांड नॉट फाउंड इसका
आउटपुट ऐसे स्क्रीन पर शो कर दिया लेकिन
एक्चुअल में मेरा इंटेंशन क्या था मैं जिस
तरह का आउटपुट चाहता था जिस तरह से मैं
चाहता था कि मेरे को जो प्रिंट होकर मिले
सचिन एंड नितेश आपको देखने को क्या मिले
आपको सचिन एंड नितेश आपको देखने को मिले
लेकिन मुझे यह देखने को नहीं मिला क्योंकि
स्पेशल कैरेक्टर की वजह से और स्पेशल
कक्टर है तो स्पेशल कक्टर क्या है अपना
मीनिंग है जो आपकी कमांड को बैकग्राउंड
में लेकर चला जाता है तो अब मैं जैसा मैं
आउटपुट चाहता हूं वैसा ही आउटपुट अगर मुझे
चाहिए तो उसके लिए मैं क्या करता हूं
कोटिंग का यूज करता हूं तो कैसे मैं उसके
कोटिंग का यूज करूंगा मैंने क्या किया
एकको सचिन और उसके बाद मैंने बैक स्लस का
यूज किया और एंड एम परट देन नितेश एन आई
टी ई एस एच नितेश आपको पता है बैकस क्या
करता है इमीडिएट जो कैरेक्टर है उसको क्या
करता स्पेस मीनिंग रिमूव कर देता मैंने
हिट एंटर कर दिया अब देखो सचिन एंड नितेश
आपको एज इट इज स्क्रीन पर देखने को मिलेगा
जैसा आउटपुट म चाहता वैसा आउटपुट मेरे को
स्क्रीन पर देखने को मिल रहा है फॉर
एग्जांपल आपके सामने कई बार एक चैलेंज आता
है
कई बार आपको स्क्रिप्ट लिखते हुए अपने
वेरिएबल के
अंदर जो आपका जो विंडोज मशीन का जो पाथ है
वो सेव करना पड़ता है कैसे फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं फाइल
पाथ फाइल पाथ इक्वल जो वेरिएबल डिफाइन
करते हैं तो उनके डिफाइन करते वक्त
वेरिएबल का नाम उसके बाद इक्वल साइन स्पेस
कभी नहीं होता उसके अंदर उसके बाद सी
ड्राइव उसके बाद कॉलन देन बैक स्ल उसके
बाद मैंने लिखा यूजर बैक स्ल मैंने लिखा
नितेश बैक स्ल मैंने लिखा डॉक्यूमेंट डी ओ
सी यू एम ई एन टी एस डॉक्यूमेंट इस तरीके
से क्या करना चाहता हूं मैं अपने इस
वेरिएबल के अंदर एक येय पाथ सेव करना
चाहता हूं विंडोज का बट क्या क्या मैं
क्या चाहता हूं विंडो में
तो विंडो में मैं क्या चाहता हूं ऐसा ही
तो चाहता हूं ना विंडो में मैं ऐसा ही
चाहता हूं कि यह सॉरी इस वेरिएबल में ऐसा
ही चाहता
हूं इस वेरिएबल में मैं क्या चाहता हूं
ऐसा ही चाहता
हूं क्या हो रहा है कोई इशू चल रहा है
क्या ग्रुप
में होल्ड ऑन
गाइस
सॉरी फॉर दैट अपने टीम से चेक कर रहा था
कि कोई प्रॉब्लम है या टेक्निकल इशू कोई
टेक्निकल इशू नहीं है फुल पाथ चेक हो गया
है अगर आपके फोम में प्रॉब्लम है अगर आपके
नेटवर्क में प्रॉब्लम है तो उसकी मेरी कोई
गारंटी नहीं है ओके तो मैं क्या करता हूं
कि फाइल पाथ के अंदर मैं सीड जो विंडोज का
पाथ सेव करना चाहता हूं तो मैं क्या चाहता
हूं मैं जो मेरा इंटेंशन है एजट सेव करने
का लेकिन मैंने क्या किया हिट एंटर कर
दिया और जब मैंने एक को किया और डॉलर और
मैं क्या करता हूं फाइल पाथ फाइल पाथ ट
एंटर कर दिया अब देखो यह स्टोर कैसे हुआ
सी यूजर नितेश डॉक्यूमेंट लेकिन मैं इसको
एज इट इज तो सेव नहीं करना चाहता था ना
मैं क्या चाहता था कि ये ऐसे से हो स सेमी
कलन कॉलन फिर बैक स्लश फिर यूजर फिर बैक
स्लस फते फिर बैक स्लस फ डॉक्यूमेंट यसे
से हो लेकिन ये आया कैसे आउटपुट में ऐसे
शो हुआ क्योंकि जो बैक स्लस है ये भी अपने
आप में एक स्पेशल कैरेक्टर्स का भी अपना
एक स्पेशल मीनिंग है अगर मुझे क्या करना
है इसका स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव करना है तो
आपको पता है मुझे कोटिंग का यूज करना होगा
कोटिंग मैं कैसे यूज करूंगा फाइल पाथ फाइल
पाथ है उसके बाद मैं क्या करूंगा इसके आगे
मैं एक और बैक स्लैक्स का यूज करूंगा एक
और बैक स्लैश यूज किया इसके आगे भी एक और
बैक स्लैश यूज किया इसके आगे भी मैंने एक
और बैक स्लैश का यूज किया हिट एंटर कर
दिया अब जब मैं एकको डॉलर पाथ फाइल पाथ
करता हूं तो अभी देखो जैसा आउटपुट मुझे
चाहिए था स्क्रीन पर वैसा ही आउटपुट आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है सी हैज यूजर नितेश
डॉक्यूमेंट ऐसा ही आउटपुट आपको स्क्रीन पर
देखने मिल रहा है और ऐसा ही आउटपुट आप ऐसा
ही जो पाथ है आप अपनी मशीन के अंदर सेव
करना चाहते थे लेकिन अब आपके सामने
प्रॉब्लम क्या है कि ये इस तरीके से किसी
भी एक बिगनर के लिए लिए कोटिंग को डिफाइन
करना एक हार्ड पार्ट है एक हेक्टिक पार्ट
है क्योंकि एक बिगनर क्या है कि अगर कुछ
ज्यादा लंबी कमांड होगी कुछ ज्यादा लंबा
पाथ ऐड करना होगाया ज्यादा कोटिंग का यूज
करना पड़ गया तो वो क्या कंफ्यूज हो जाएगा
वहां पर एरर की प्रॉब्लम हो सकती है एरर
जनरेट हो सकती है वो गलती कर सकता है तो
इसका भी अल्टरनेट सॉल्यूशन क्या आपको पता
है अल्टरनेट सलूशन क्या करोगे आप क्या
करोगे अल्टरनेट सॉल्यूशन को सिंपली आप
इसको क्या कर दोगे सिंगल कोट के अंदर इसके
अंदर क्या करो सिंगल कोट के अंदर स्टोर कर
दोगे सिंपली सिंगल कोट के अंदर लगा दोगे ट
एंटर कर दिया अब एक को डॉलर पाथ किया तो
सेम एज इट जैसा मुझे आउटपुट चाहिए था वैसा
ही आउटपुट इस हमें स्क्रीन पर शो हो रहा
है जैसा यूजर चाहता था वैसा ही उसके
अकॉर्डिंग काम हो रहा है क्योंकि मैं नहीं
चाहता कि जो स्पेशल कैरेक्टर्स उनका
स्पेशल मीनिंग आपको स्क्रीन पर शो हो या
मैं नहीं चाहता किसी वेरिएबल के अंदर
स्टोर हो समझ में आ गया आपको यह चीज अब
फॉर एग्जांपल एक और चीज है कि मैं क्या
चाहता हूं अब की जो फाइल पाथ है मैं फाइल
पाथ के अंदर एक काम करना चाहता हूं फाइल
पाथ है जो मेरा वेरिएबल उसके अंदर ठीक है
सिंगल कोट है चलो मैं लास्ट ला सिंगल कोट
है तो अब मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं बारबार
यहां नितेश लिखने की बजाय अगर मैं लोकल
नेटवर्क में या जिसके लिए भी मैं
स्क्रिप्ट राइट कर रहा हूं हर बार उसका
नाम तो मैं मेंशन नहीं करूंगा हर एक के
लिए अलग तो स्क्रिप्ट बनाऊंगा नहीं मैं
ऐसा चाहता हूं कि ऑटोमेट उसका नाम यहां पर
ऐड हो जाए तो सिंपली मैंने क्या किया डॉलर
और यूएस ईयर यहां पर लिख दिया डॉलर यूजर
लिख दिया मैंने अब मैंने क्या कर दिया
डॉलर यूजर कर दिया अब मैं क्या कर दिया
मैंने डॉलर यूजर यहां पर कर दिया और हिट
एंटर कर दिया अभी मैं आउटपुट कैसा चाहता
हूं मैं चाहता हूं जो मेरा फाइल पाथ
वेरिएबल उसके अंदर आउटपुट ऐसे शो होना
चाहिए लेकिन ऐसे शो नहीं होगा तो मैं क्या
करता हूं एकको फाइल पाथ हिट एंटर अभी देखो
मैं क्या चाहता था ये बट प्रॉब्लम क्या है
कि जो डॉलर डॉलर यूजर्स है यहां पर मैं
चाहता था कि यह अपना काम करे और डॉलर यूजर
अपना काम करे और इसका जो इसकी जगह ड
रिप्लेस करे जो भी इसका यूजर नेम है यूजर
नेम के साथ क्या इसको रिप्लेस करे बट ये
इसको रिप्लेस कर नहीं रहा है क्योंकि जो
डॉलर सिंबल था ये एक स्पेशल कैरेक्टर है
इसने अपना इसका स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव कर
दिया इसने क्या कर दिया स्पेशल मीनिंग
रिमूव कर दिया तो अब मैं क्या करता हूं
इसका अल्टरनेट सलूशन क्या है सिंपली मैं
क्या करता हूं मैं इसको यूज करता हूं आप
बोलोगे सर डबल कोट के अंदर यूज कर लो तो
यह काम करेगा मैंने इसका क्या कर दिया डबल
कोट के अंदर इसको मैंने यूज करना शुरू कर
दिया अब मैं क्या डबल कोट के अंदर डबल कोट
और उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया यह रहा और
हिट एंटर कर दिया अब मैं एकको फाइल पाथ
आपके सामने करके देता हूं अब भी आपके
सामने एक प्रॉब्लम आई जैसा आउटपुट आप
चाहते थे वैसा आउटपुट आपको स्क्रीन पर शो
हो नहीं रहा है वैसा आउटपुट आपको स्क्रीन
पर शो नहीं हो रहा है देख ये रहा ऐसा
आउटपुट आपको स्क्रीन पर शो नहीं हो रहा
जैसा आप चाहते थे तो अब मैं क्या करूंगा
इसके लिए अब इसके लिए मुझे क्या करना होगा
किसको यहां पर किसी को समझ में आ रहा है
कि किसी को समझ में आ रहा है कि यहां पर
हो क्या रहा है चल क्या रहा है किसी को भी
प किसी को अगर कांसेप्ट क्लियर हो किसी
को समझ में आ रहा है कि ऐसा क्यों हुआ
मैंने तो बोला था कि भैया डबल कोट के अंदर
जितने भी कैरेक्टर्स है उनका स्पेशल
मीनिंग रिमूव हो जाता है एक्सेप्ट डॉलर
साइन एंड बैकटिक्स तो डॉलर साइन है डॉलर
साइन क्या है यूजर वेरिएबल का जो वैल्यू
है जो यूजर नेम है यहां पर वो आना उसकी
वैल्यू होनी चाहिए बट वो आई क्यों नहीं वो
आई क्यों नहीं डज एनी वन टेल मी ऑन द
चैट चलो चैट में और ही कुछ चल रहा है मैं
उसकी तरफ ध्यान नहीं देता ऐसा इसलिए हुआ
क्योंकि एक डबल कोट्स है डबल कोट्स के
अंदर एक फ्लेक्सिबल होती है क्या
फ्लेक्सिबल होती है कि अगर आप उसके अंदर
क्या है बैक स्लस का यूज करते हो तो बैक
स्लस क्या कर देता है कि उसके अंदर डॉलर
सिंबल है और जो बैकटिक्स है उसका भी
स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव कर देता है तो अब एक
फ्लेक्सिबल दी हुई है उस फ्लेक्सिबल का हम
यहां पर यूज कर सकते हैं अब मैं क्या
चाहता हूं क्योंकि ठीक है इसने इसका
स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव कर दिया बट मैं क्या
चाहता हूं कि अब मैं इसका स्पेशल मीनिंग
रिमूव करना चाहता हूं ताकि ये डॉलर यूजर
अपना काम करें लेकिन क्या आउटपुट में मेरा
क्या आना चाहिए स्लैश यूजर स्लैश उसके बाद
डॉलर यूजर यूजर नेम उसके बाद ये आना चाहिए
ओके तो अब मैं क्या करता हूं कि मैं इसको
सिंपली इसके आगे एक बैक स्लैश का यूज करता
हूं उसके आगे मैं क्या करता हूं एक बैक
स्लैश का यूज करता हूं तो मैंने क्या किया
एकको उसके बाद फिर डॉलर फाइल पाथ उसके
फाइल पाथ यूज किया ट एंटर अब देखो अब जो
इसने क्या कर दिया जो यूजर है उसी यूजर का
नाम शो गया है सी यूजर रूट डॉक्यूमेंट अभी
इसने जैसा आउटपुट मुझे चाहिए था जैसा
आउटपुट आपको चाहिए था वैसा ही आउटपुट इसने
क्या कर दिया आपके इस वेरिएबल के अंदर
स्टोर किया स्टोर कर दिया तो ये आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा कि जो कोटिंग है उसको कैसे
यूज किया जाता है कोटिंग को कैसे यूज किया
जाता है और कितनी पावरफुल है अब जैसे-जैसे
हम सेशन के साथ आगे बढ़ेंगे जैसे-जैसे
ये बैस कैसे प्रोसेस करती है उसके बारे
में पढ़ेंगे और जैसे-जैसे हम कमांड्स की
प्रैक्टिस करें तो आपको पता चल जाए कि ये
कितनी पावरफुल आपके हर एक पार्ट को कैसे
अफेक्ट करती आई होप कि सबको य समझ में आगा
जो कोटिंग है यह कैसे काम करता है
प्रैक्टिकली मैंने आपको करके दिखा दिया है
प्रैक्टिकली मैंने आपको इसको करके दिखा
दिया है अब हम एक काम करते हैं अपने
फर्स्ट स्टेप पर चलते हैं हम बैक ू अपने
सीट पर चलते और क्या करते फर्स्ट स्टेप पर
चलते हैं जो फर्स्ट स्टेप हमारा कौन सा
आता है आप सबको पता है जो फर्स्ट स्टेप है
व है टोकना इजेशन आज हम टोकेनाइजेशन पढ़ने
वाले हैं फ स्टेप के बारे में थोड़ा सा
फिर से थ्योरी आ गया यह समझना बहुत ही
ज्यादा जरूरी अगर थ्योरी नहीं समझोगे तो
आपको फ थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लम हो सकती है तो
है स्टेप वन स्टेप जीरो वन जिसको हम बोलते
हैं टोकेनाइजेशन टी ओ के ई
एन आई एस ए टी टोकेनाइजेशन हम बोलेंगे
टोकना इजेशन अब यह होता क्या है इसके बारे
में आपको बताऊंगा एक
मिनट इसको हाईलाइट कर देते हैं लाट हो गया
औरन इसका थोड़ा सा कलर चेंज कर देते हैं
ओके
चलो टोकेनाइजेशन होता क्या है अब मैं आपको
बताता
हूं अभी क्या है कि आपको पता है कि कमांड
लाइन होती क्या है ओके तो अभी कोटिंग के
बारे में मैंने आपको बताया कोटिंग का सबसे
पहले जानना बहुत ही ज्यादा जरूरी था इसलिए
उसको मैंने आपको पहले बता दिया अब फर्स्ट
स्टेप के बारे में बात करते हैं अब क्या
होता है कि बस
हैज सर्टेन बस
सर्टेन सर्टेन मेटा कैरेक्टर मेटा
सी सर्टेन मेटा कैरेक्टर ट
अलाउ इट
टू ब्रेक अप
ए कमांड
लाइन
इनटू टस इनटू
ट नोन एज
टोकन नन एज टोकन ओके
चस बोल सकते हैं च ओके तोय समझ में आया
आपको इसको कलर चेंज कर देता
आपके चलो अब क्या होता है कि इसका मतलब
क्या है
कि कुछ स्पेशल कुछ मेटा कैरेक्टर्स होते
हैं बैच के अंदर जो क्या करते हैं आपकी
कमांड लाइन को चस में डिवाइड कर देते हैं
जिनको हम बोलते हैं टोकन अब मैं टोकन को
अगर डेफिनेशन दू टोकन क्या है व्ट
इज टोकन अगर मैं इसके बारे में आपको बताऊं
टोकन क्या होते हैं तो उसके बारे में आपको
बता देता हूं कि
ए सीक्वेंस एस ए क यू ई एन
सीई सीक्वेंस ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स
सीक्वेंस ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स
ट
इज कंसीडर्ड एज
ए सिंगल यूनिट कंसीडर्ड एज ए सिंगल यूनिट
बाय द सेल ओके ट इ कड कंसीडर्ड एज ए सिंगल
यूनिट बाय द तो टोकस भी है मतलब क्या है
कि एक कैरेक्टर्स का
सीक्वेंस जो सीक्वेंस में होंगे और उनको
क्या बोलेंगे एज ए सिंगल यूनिट कंसीडर
करेंगे उसको बोल सेल के द्वारा सेल के
द्वारा एक सीक्वेंस ऑफ कैरेक्टर को एज ए
सिंगल यट कंसीडर किया जाएगा उसको हम क्या
बोलते हैं टोकस अभी क्या है कि जो आपकी
बैस है इसमें क्या है जो मेटा कैरेक्टर्स
है वो 10 टाइप के है दे 10 टाइप्स ऑफ मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स देयर
आर
10 टाइप्स ऑफ मेटा कैरेक्टर्स
सी एच ए आ मेटा कक्ट देर 10 टाइप्स ऑफ
मेटा ओके दे आर 10 टाइप्स ऑफ मेटा इसको
मैं क्या करता हूं थोड़ा सा लाट करता हूं
आप लोगों के लिए
न अब 10 टाइप के मेटा कक्टर कौन से है एक
तो ये आपका पाइप सिमल आपको इसको टब के साथ
करता हूं टटर टब के साथ एक दूसरा कौन सा
आपका दूसरा आपका एम परसेंट दूसरा क्या
आपका एम
परसेंट एक मिट इसको भी थोड़ा सा अच्छे से
दिखने
दो दूसरा क्या है आपका ए पर तीसरा क्या है
सेमीकलन
रारा क्या है सेमीकलन फोर्थ क्या है ओपन
ब्रैकेट फिफ्थ क्या है क्लोज ब्रैकेट
सिक्स क्या है लेस देन सिंबल सेवंथ क्या
है ग्रेटर देन
सिंबल उसके बाद एथ क्या है स्स स्पेस उसके
बाद क्या है स्पेस नाइन क्या है टैब एंड
न्यू लाइन न्यू लाइन ये सारी के सारी ये
क्या है 10 मेटा कैरेक्टर्स है जिनके
बेसिस पर क्या करते आपके आपके जो बैस है
उस उसको क्या करता है आपकी कमांड को ब्रेक
करता है चंगस के अंदर टोकेंस के अंदर ओके
मैं इनका क्या करता हूं एक बार कलर चेंज
करता हूं सो आपके लिए इजी हो जाएगा आपके
लिए इजी है हो
जाएगा ओके ये आपको पता चल गया होगा
नेक्स्ट
अभी जब एक बार क्या है कि सेल क्या करता
है कि एक बार रफ आईडिया लगा लेता है कि
आपके जो कमांड्स को ब्रेक करके टोकन का एक
बार रफ आईडिया लगा ता कि टोकन कहां क पर
और रफ आईडिया कैसे लगाता है ऑन द बेसिस ऑफ
दज मेटा कैरेक्टर ऑन द बेसिस ऑफ दज मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स नॉट ओनली मेटा कैरेक्टर ऑन द
बेसिस ऑफ अनकोटेड
मेटा गेटिंग माय पॉइंट ऑन द बेसिस ऑफ
अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर
जो क्या है टोकन का आईडिया सेल कैसे लगा
जाता है ऑन द बेसिस
ऑफ
सेल टेक्स
द टे
द रफ आईडिया
ऑफ रफ आइडिया ऑफ
टोकन बाय
फाइंडिंग फाइंडिंग अनकोटेड
अनकोटेड
य ओके अनकोटेड मेटा कक्टर
मेटा अनकोटेड मेटा कक्टर इसके बेसिस पर
क्या करता है य रफ आईडिया लगाता जब एक बार
रफ आईडिया लगा लिया उसके बाद क्या करता है
इन टोकस को फरदर दो कैटेगरी में डिवाइड
करता
है फदर क्या करता है
ज
टोकन
फदर डिवाइडेड
इनटू टू कैटेगरी
दो कैटेगरी में ओके वो दो कौन-कौन सी है
फर्स्ट है जिसको हम बोलेंगे वो है आपका
वर्ड्स जिसको हम क्या कर रहे हैं वर्ड
वर्ड में और दूसरी जो कैटेगरी है उसको हम
बोलेंगे ऑपरेटर के अंदर ओ पी ई आर
ए टी ओ आर ऑपरेटर के अंदर इन दो कैटेगरी
के अंदर टोकेंस को बाद में डिवाइड कर दिया
जाता है एक बार रफ आईडिया लगाने के बाद अब
ये वर्ड्स क्या होते हैं वर्ड्स के बारे
में आपको बताता वर्ड्स होता क्या है चलो
वर्ड्स के बारे में आपको डिफाइन करता
हूं
दोज टोकेंस
आर
दोज टोकस
आर डिफाइंड
एज वर्ड डिफाइंड ए वर्ड्स
ट डज
नॉट डज
नॉट
कंटेन एनी अनकोटेड
अनकोटेड मेटा
कैरेक्टर अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स ओके
इसका मतलब क्या है
कि टोकन में वर्ड उनको बोला
जाएगा मेटा वड्स उनको बोला जाएगा जिनके
अंदर एक भी मेटा कैरेक्टर्स नहीं है
अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर उसको हम डिफाइन
करेंगे एज ए वर्ड जब मैं प्रैक्टिकली
दिखाऊंगा आपको पता चल जाएगा कि हम वर्ड
कैसे डिफाइन कर रहे हैं और ऑपरेटर कैसे
डिफाइन कर ब डेफिनेशन य है दोस टोकन आ
डिफाइंड व ट ड नॉट कंटेन एनी अनकोटेड मेटा
कक्टर ओके
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट आपको बताता हूं की
दोज
दोज टोकन
आर डिफाइंड एज
ऑपरेटर
ऑपरेटर्स
ट
कंटेंस
एटलीस्ट
वन अनकोटेड
अनकोटेड
मेटा मेटा कक्टर ओके अनकोटेड मेटा
ओके अनकोटेड मेटा कक्ट बेसिकली क्या है कि
जो वर्ड्स है और ऑपरेटर में डिफरेंस य है
कि वर्ड्स उस टोकन को वर्ड बोला जाएगा
जिसके अंदर एक भी अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स
नहीं होगा एक भी अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स
नहीं होगा और जिसके अंदर एटलीस्ट एक भी
मेटा कैरेक्टर होगा उसको हम बोलेंगे
ऑपरेटर आई होप कि आपको समझ में आ रहा होगा
डेफिनेशन ज्यादा टिपिकल नहीं है लेकिन हां
स्टार्टिंग में आपको अभी समझने थोड़ी सी
टिपिकल हो गई क्योंकि क्या मतलब बोला टोकन
वर्ड ऑपरेटर अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स
कोटेड मेटा कक्टर अनकोटेड और कोटेड देखो
कोटेड ये वही चीज आगी जो अभी एक मिनट पहले
मैंने बताया था कि कोटिंग क्या होती है
रिमूविंग द स्पेशल मीनिंग फ्रॉम स्पेशल
कैरेक्टर्स उसके बाद तीन टाइप्स की होती
है और एक बार किसी कैरेक्टर को अगर स्पेशल
मीनिंग रिमूव कर उसको हम बोलते हैं कोटेड
अगर किसी का कैरेक्टर स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव
नहीं किया तो उसको हम बोलते हैं अनकोटेड
तोय यहां पर बात हो रही है अनकोटेड मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स की डज नॉट कंटेन एनी अनकोटेड
मेटा कैरेक्टर
और एटलीस्ट जिसके अंदर एक अनकोटेड मेटा
कैरेक्टर है जिके अंदर क्या एटलीस्ट एक
अनकोटेड मेटा कक्टर है उसका हम बोलेंगे
ऑपरेटर्स उसको हम बोलेंगे ऑपरेटर ओके मुझे
लगता है आपको यह समझ में आ रहा
होगा चलो यही की डिफरेंस दोनों बीच में अब
य जो ऑपरेटर है ना यह ऑपरेटर भी दो टाइप्स
के
फदर
दज
ऑपरेटर्स
ओ ऑपरेटर्स
आर आल्सो टू टाइप्स यह भी दो टाइप्स के
होते हैं यह दो टाइप के कनकन से होते हैं
मैं आपको बताता सबसे पहला होता है सबसे
पहला जिसको हम बोलते हैं वह है आपका
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर व
आपका कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर जो सेकंड है उसको
हम बोलते बोते रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर
री रीडायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर उसको हम बोलते
हैं रीडायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर अब यह कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर कौन से होते
हैं बेसिकली कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर वो होते हैं
जो क्या करते हैं आपकी कमांड्स को प्रोसेस
करने का काम करते हैं कंट्रोल करने का काम
करते हैं वह होते हैं कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर्स और
जो रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर कौन से होते हैं वो
क्या करते हैं जो जो भी आपका आउटपुट आता
है उसको कहां पर रीडायरेक्ट करना है आप
टर्मिनल पर शो करना है या किसी फाइल के
अंदर शो करना है या किसी दूसरी कमांड का
एज ए इनपुट बनाना है तो वे आता है
रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर्स के अंदर अभी मैं
आपको बताता हूं कि ये कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर्स
कौन-कौन से होते हैं और रीडायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर कौन-कौन से होते हैं ये भी आपको
मैं देखो सभी आपके बारे में आपके दरा
जानने की जरूरत नहीं है सभी को सभी जितने
आपको पता होने चाहिए वो आपको पहले से पता
होंगे या क्लास के दौरान पता चल जाएंगे बट
क्या कि अगर आपका ओन इंटरेस्ट है तो आप
खुद से जान सकते हैं और मैक्सिमम के बारे
में आप जानते होंगे तो मैं बात करता हूं
इसकी कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर के अंदर कौन-कौन से
आते हैं सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर क्या
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर के अंदर कौन-कौन से आते
हैं लिस्ट कौन सी आती है कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर
के अंदर आता है देखो न्यू लाइन न्यू लाइन
आती है एक तो उसके मैं कॉमा सेपरेट लिख
रहा हूं सबको न्यू लाइन उसके बाद आता है
सिंगल पाइप सिंबल डबल पाइप
सिंबल उसके बाद आता है एम परसेंट उसके बाद
आता है डबल एम
परसेंट नेक्स्ट आता है इसके अंदर सेमीकलन
नेक्स्ट आता है उसके बाद डबल सेमीकलन
नेक्स्ट आता है आपका सेमीकलन और एंड मैं
आपको इनको थोड़ा क्या करता हूं थोड़ा गैप
आपको समझ में आ जाएगा
सोलो
य
ये रहा उसके बाद क्या है कॉमा सेपरेटेड
उसके बाद आता है डबल सेमीकलन और एंड उसके
बाद आता
है पाइप सिंबल और एंड उसके बाद यह सारे
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर के पार्ट है ये सारे
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर के पार्ट है उसके बाद आता
है ओपन ब्रैकेट उसके बाद नेक्स्ट आता है
आपका क्लोज ब्रैकेट मैं इनको एक बार क्या
करता हूं हाईलाइट भी करता हूं आपको और भी
आसानी से याद रह
जाएंगे उसके बाद यह
रहा य
रहा
ओके ये है अब बात करते हैं डायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर कौन से अब बात करते हैं
रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर कौन से होते
हैं अब
रीडायरेक्शन डायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर ओ
[संगीत]
पीई डायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर कौन से होते हैं ओ ड
टर की बात करता हम इसको थोड़ा हाईलाइट कर
देते कलर चेंज कर देंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है अच्छा लगेगा
और नेक्स्ट अब क्या कलर हमा ब्लैक ही है
चलो अब इसके अंदर जो डायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर के
अंदर आते हैं लेसन
सिंबल कॉमा ग्रेटर देन सिंबल कॉमा उसके
बाद आता है डबल लेस देन सिंबल कॉमा
डबल ग्रेटर देन
सिंबल कमा देन उसके बाद आता है लेसन सिंबल
और एंड देन आता है उसके बाद क्या है
ग्रेटर देन सिंबल और पाइप सिंबल साथ में
नेक्स्ट जो आता है लेसन सिंबल और
हान उसके बाद कॉमा नेक्स्ट जो आता है यह
सिंबल
नेक्स्ट य आता है ग्रेटर देन सिंबल और एंड
ये सारे क्या आते आप डायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर के
अंदर आते हैं यह सारे के सारे आपके क्या
आते है रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर के अंदर आते
हैं अभी आपने एक चीज नोटिस की होगी चाहे
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर हो चाहे रीडायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर हो सारे के सारे किससे बने हुए हैं
मेटा कैरेक्टर की हेल्प से बने हैं कौन से
मेटा कैरेक्टर जो 10 मेटा कैरेक्टर हमने
ऊपर कवर किए थे उनकी हेल्प से सारे सारे
उन्हीं की हेल्प से बने हुए हैं देखो ये
रहे ये सारे के सारे उन्हीं की हेल्प से
बने हुए हैं तीन टाइप के मेटा कैप्टर तो
इसलिए आपको पता चल गया होगा
कि कि जो कोटिंग है वो आपके हर एक पार्ट
को इफेक्ट कर रही है हर एक पार्ट को
कंट्रोल कर रही है क्योंकि देखो जो
टोकेनाइजेशन जो फर्स्ट स्टेप है वो किसके
बेसिस प परफॉर्म हो रहा है कोटिंग के
बेसिस प देखो अनकोटेड मेटा कैरेक्टर्स तभी
क्या कर रहा है उसको क्या कर रहा है वो
उसमें ब्रेक कर रहा है किसके अंदर टोकेंस
के अंदर ब्रेक कर रहा है और जब टोकेंस को
या तो एज ए वर्ड कंसीडर किया जाएगा या ए
ऑपरेटर और ऑपरेटर के अंदर भी कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर और रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर एज कंसीडर
किया जाएगा आई होप कि सबको समझ में आएगा
कि ये है आपका टोकेनाइज स्टेप टोकना स्टेप
बता देता हूं क्या है टोकेनाइजेशन स्टेप
में सिंपली क्या है कि जो कमांड है कमांड
को मेटा कैरेक्टर के बेसिस पर चंक्स में
डिवाइड कर दिया जाता है या जिनको हम
टोकेंस बोल सकते हैं टोकेंस वे होते हैं
एक सीरीज है एक सीरीज ऑफ कैरेक्टर्स जिसको
कंसीडर किया जाएगा एज ए सिंगल यूनिट उसको
हम बोलते हैं टोकन जब एक बार मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स के बेसिस पर आपका जो बैस है या
सेल है एक रफ आइडिया ले लेता है कि मेरे
टोकेंस कहां-कहां पर है फर्द इन टोकेंस को
दो कैटेगरी में डिवाइड कर दिया जाता है एक
तो कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर एक रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर
अब कंट्रोल
ऑपरेटर सॉरी वर्ड्स और ऑपरेटर्स में
डिवाइड कर दिया जाता है एक बार उसके बाद
क्या है कि वर्ड्स तो डिवाइड हो गए व
वर्ड्स कौन से होंगे वर्ड्स भी होंगे जो
जिसके अंदर कोई भी अनकोटेड मेटा
कैरेक्टर्स नहीं है उसको एज ए वर्ड माना
जाएगा और एज ए ऑपरेटर उस टोकन को कंसीडर
किया जाएगा जिसके अंदर एटलीस्ट वन अनकोटेड
मेटा कैरेक्टर्स है उसके बाद ऑपरेटर्स एक
बार किसी को पता चल गया कि यहां पर
ऑपरेटर्स है को कंसीडर कर लिया उसके बाद
ये ढूंढा जाएगा कि फर्द भी ऑपरेटर में कि
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर है या रीडायरेक्शन ऑपरेटर
है और उसी के बेसिस पर उसी के आधार पर
क्या किया जाए उसका टास्क परफॉर्म किया
जाएगा इसका प्रैक्टिकल क्या है कि
जैसे-जैसे हम स्टेप टू में जाएंगे स्टेप
थ्री में जाएंगे तो हम क्या करेंगे ज
स्टेप टू पढ़ने से पहले हम स्टेप वन का जो
का प्रैक्टिकल है वो होगा उसके बाद स्टेप
टू हम जंप करेंगे अब आगे आगे क्या है कि
जैसे स्टेप थ्री में जाएंगे तो स्टेप थ्री
में जो भी एग्जांपल लेंगे उसका सबसे पहले
हम यह बताएंगे कि यहां पर टोकेनाइजेशन हुआ
यहां पर कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन हुआ अब स्टेप
थ्री आ गया ऐसे स्टेप फोर स्टेप फाइव जब
एक बार आपके पांचों स्टेप परफॉर्म हो
जाएंगे उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे कि तीन या
दो एग्जांपल से फुल रिवीजन करेंगे कि यहां
पर टोकना स्टेप हुआ कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
स्टेप हुआ सेल उसका थर्ड स्टेप हुआ फोर्थ
स्टेप हुआ उसके बाद फिफ्थ स्टेप हुआ ये
सारे स्टेप्स हुए ये आपको फिर पूरा रफ
आईडिया हो जाएगा जब भी आप क्या करो अपना
स्क्रिप्टिंग करोगे तो आपको ये सारी
छोटी-छोटी चीजें ध्यान में रहेंगी जिससे
आपकी एरर्स होने के चांसेस बहुत कम होंगे
और कम एरर्स वाली आप अपनी खुद की
स्क्रिप्ट बना पाओगे उसके बाद हम असली चीज
स्टार्ट करेंगे क्योंकि यह कांसेप्ट उस
आने वाली चीजों के लिए बहुत ज्यादा
इंपोर्टेंट है अगर यह कांसेप्ट किसी को भी
नहीं पता भले आप कितने ही मास्टर्स बस्ट
स्क्रिप्टिंग के प्रोब्लेमे िक है उसके
बाद हम कंटिन्यू स्टार्ट हो जाएंगे कमांड
बोल ये फॉर वाइल लूप है फॉर लूप है देन
उसके बाद अरेज बहुत कुछ है उसके बाद हम
एंड करेंगे दो से चार प्रोजेक्ट के बीच
में लेंगे व प्रोजेक्ट आप रियल ली कैसे हम
प्रोजेक्ट डिजाइन करते हैं उसका आईडिया
आपको मिल जाएगा तो आज की क्लास इतनी थी आज
का स्टेप वन कंप्लीट करेंगे फर्द हम स्टेप
टू है जो कमांड आइडेंटिफिकेशन नेक्स्ट
क्लास में कंप्लीट करेंगे वो छोटा सा है
तो हम स्टेप थ्री भी स्टार्ट कर देंगे अदर
वाइज क्या टाइम रह गया तो अगर टाइम नहीं
रहा तो हम स्टार्ट नहीं करेंगे तो दे फाइव
मिनट फॉर द डाउट सेशन तो अगर किसी को लगता
है कि कि किसी का कोई डाउट्स है आज के और
प्रीवियस क्लास के टॉपिक्स में कोई भी
डाउट्स है समझ में नहीं आया तो टॉपिक
रिलेटेड ही डाउट्स यहां पर प्रेजेंट करना
उसको मैं यहां पर सेम टाइम आपके सॉल्व
करूंगा अदर वाइज जो आउट ऑफ सिलेबस जो
डाउट्स है वो यहां पर पुट अप मत करना
क्योंकि बैस से ही रिलेटेड आपके डाउट्स
होने चाहिए क्योंकि उसके लिए भी आप सेपरेट
क्लासेस होंगे या सेपरेट कोर्सेस होंगे
उसमें क्या कर सकते हो वो पूछ सकते
हो तो मैं आपके लिए 5 मिनट वेट करता हूं
अगर 5 मिनट में या नेक्स्ट वन मिनट में
अगर किसी का कोई डाउट नहीं आ तो फिर मैं
क्लास को एंड कर दूंगा अरवाज पा मिनट हम
वेट करेंगे बट आई डोंट नो कि ये ग्रुप में
क्या चल रहा है
ब
ओके तो सेशन एंड करते हैं बाय बाय गुड
नाइट टेक केयर सी य फर नेक्स्ट सेशन किसी
का कोई डाउट नहीं है
तो